hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to power wash simulator
we have a big job ahead of us
and i don't know if i'm going to be able
to do this all in one episode
but it seems like something that would
be appealing to me
it's a big-ass treehouse in the middle
of the woods because everything in this
universe seems to be in the middle of
the woods i don't know why
when you're on an island with a volcano
you just seem to want to go into the
woods
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute what's with this cardboard
backdrop here
what's with this gar it's all fake
why is it all fake also why are there
cameras here
hello that's a little weird
ew i've got multiple oh my god do i have
to get the underside
oh no okay so this job is kind of nuts
um what is that
is that the volcano about to bloom
is that a giant stomping through the
woods blinding
yeah apparently we're about to die also
sorry for the shitty lighting in this
place i didn't bring any lights with me
to austin to film
ice 2 and you know i need to go get some
all right
best you just start with the basics i
suppose
should i heed these warnings
[Music]
huh
well that was all the ground accessories
i think
holy crap this is going to take so long
but it's not an impossibility uh so long
as i take this
kind of methodically and i go through it
meticulously
it shouldn't take me that long because
for the most part it's all wood
like it's all wood so the undersides i
can probably take care of with soap
because they're big
open areas and these little detail areas
will probably need some hand work but
everything else is just wood so honestly
like
not that bad it's bad
but it's not that bad let's see if we
can take care of this
oh the white seems to take care of this
one
yeah i can use the wide angle on this
one it's not too bad
i still don't know what the thumping is
it's probably fine
but if it's not fine and i'm about to
die
i would like to at least know what is
exploding in the background
uh-huh this is not going to tell me i
i just have to assume that the ominous
exploding that's happening all around me
is just perfectly normal
[Music]
you tell me see these segments are
individuals
oh no
oh this is going to be a bear of a job
this is going to be a
blast of a job but i'm up to the task
and i seem to be making a lot of
progress on it i just don't know who
makes
a treehouse in the middle of the woods
and why and why do you abandoned it
why do you spend so much time and effort
making something and then completely
abandon it i say as my job is entirely
that
cleaning things so that they can just
get dirty again and then i can come back
and
clean it all over again nothing i do is
ever actually appreciated
only enjoyed and then thrown away
something probably profound in what i'm
saying but i'm not making much sense
i've got the wash madness too many water
fumes getting in my brain
i'm not able to control my thoughts
anymore just because i'm so enamored
with the wash
[Music]
there's something profound about like
constantly trying to
undo nature's grip on things well we as
humans just define something as being
green
i guess it doesn't really matter oh i
don't really care i'm just blasting away
digital dirt i'm not even actually
making anything
clean in the real world it's all fake
it's all just a lie it's
ones and zeros it's just a series of
ones that i'm turning back to zero with
the power of my walk
it all doesn't really matter especially
this
like i can say all the profound things i
want about the nature of reality being
this argument against fighting against
chaos but
i'm doing this in a video game it's not
even real
the situation that was constructed is
totally artificial
my brain my brain i just want to wash
things why is this not
done how much more could you want in the
steps
[Music]
okay oh starting to get some progress
down here
got a long way to go though i'm only 13
i might as well get the grill i guess
blam get in those crevasses
get rust to be gone rust with all your
tetanus crap
to this day i still don't fully
understand tetanus is it a virus
is it just rust going in the bloodstream
and that causing terrible things to
happen
i don't know and i don't care i haven't
had my booster in a bit
i probably need my booster you know rust
is kind of [ __ ]
i mean not in real life i'm talking
about in the game it's kind of [ __ ]
just get clean damn it i just blast
and i blast and i keep blasting and yet
oh there we go finally something on this
thing is gonna get clean
how about you guys you gas bottles you
gonna get clean no
no you're not why get there
get clean sometimes these things just
don't look
dirty like i can't tell what's dirty and
what's not
oh my god get clean there we go whoa
i hate this barbecue i hate this
barbecue
ah there we go there we go
okay there's something else here the
grill
itself okay you're done
you're done you done your grill that
took forever
it's time to bust out the soap we're
gonna need this because if we don't get
soap
we are gonna be screwed
good thing it's also it's all wood even
the tree i can get
cleaned
still not sure what the weird sounds in
the middle of the woods are
probably not a big deal again
the thumping very strange very strange
almost at this point i would rather it
be a volcano because if it's not a
volcano then i have
so many other questions okay once again
i'm realizing that soap is a terrible
decision and everyone who uses soap is a
big bubble blown baby and doesn't
deserve to actually power wash
because it just doesn't work you know
what i'm saying the soap just doesn't
work
not worth it not worth it at all
see what was the point of going through
this with soap if i just have to do it
all again by hand
soap is for babies so i don't know why
every time i'm like oh yeah
soap soap should work you know it like
soap
it's a good concept like the cleaning
agent it makes sense but
at the same time it does not work how
you think it would work
hello why aren't you done yet why is
nothing
done in a timely manner here
like seriously what oh god of course
oh see there's a beneficial mechanic of
being able to like angle your
uh movement like where you point down in
your power washing and you kind of slow
down based on this
the depth of your angle but there's
nothing really like that for side to
side movement which i think is
unfortunate
however i guess if you actually no there
is no because if you go full up no
that's weird because like if i go down
if i'm straight on and i'm trying to
sweep side i just go too fast so i guess
i could crouch
that's the only way to do it i just got
to get good
because all i i'm saying is i just gotta
get better at the game
is that a face i just erased look see
and go back and check to see if that was
a horrible face
[Applause]
i can give you some missing link facts
based on what i found so far if you like
missing link you talking bigfoot is this
bigfoot volcano island
[Music]
that's getting better okay now i'm
starting to feel out what this level is
it's amazing that each level does kind
of have its own feel to it
like whenever you look at it from a
bird's eye view it's like super daunting
and it's like
holy crap this intricate level is just
so
freaking beefy and then it's got these
weird challenges to each one like
the obstacles in the middle of it that
make me not able to do the kind of strip
like strafing sweeps that i would
normally like to do
and yet once you find like the rhythm to
it and you find like the order to it
you kind of get used to the level you
kind of calibrate to it because there is
like some
i hesitate to say skill but kind of like
planning that you need to go into
attacking some of these and i
definitely did not do uh the planning
correctly on the initial phase of this
kind of like i think maybe a top-down
approach would have been better for this
as opposed to a bottom-up approach
so i'm going to switch it up once i get
this particular section done
because once once i get this down it's
going to be a little bit easier
approaching the other areas what am i
missing on this picnic table
yeah but also there's things like
there's grain in the wood that makes it
a little difficult to see
so it's hard to spot exactly what is
dirt
and what is just the color of the wood
and like when things are wet sometimes
it can hide it
so like understanding the materials that
you're working with is another part of
the game that
that many uh amateur players would
overlook
but not me i want to know this game
inside and out
okay so now officially this lower deck
is done and that's the first
deck on the whole thing there's many
other things and and there's that
building up there which i don't even
know what that's gonna entail
but it's all doable that's the big thing
to remember it's all doable
even though this is private property and
everyone's saying to stay out it's
definitely doable
it feels like uh leftover from the
forest to someone who did not
make it so what i'm going to do now is
i'm going to do the top down approach
i'm going to go literally from the tippy
top and i'm going to go down because i
feel like that might actually be
a little bit of a better feel to it and
of course the thing at the tippy top is
a
rusted point
man that rust is baked
[Music]
oh my god it's all rusted oh
god i just realized i thought this thing
was its own thing this roof cap
no oh it's all of this oh my god
this is oh no this
is where metal cleaner does come in
handy
this is what this is for oh my god
metal cleaner please save me from myself
oh thank you oh my god if i had to power
nozzle this whole roof
i would have lost my mind i i feel like
i actually legitimately
legitimately might have lost my mind i
see i see icsc
there we go all right now that that
nightmare has
ended i can move on to the rest of the
rest of the nightmare roof
oh so much for starting at the top
[Music]
what is whomping in the woods what
whomps in the woods the things that go
thump in the woods need to shut up
[Music]
i'm gonna like laugh when this is like
slenderman's
thumpy thumps and it's gonna suddenly
the sun's gonna go down
and i'm just gonna start hearing the
thumping and then i better not look and
i got only my power washer to defend me
from slenderman
and that's that's gonna be just to be a
blast from the past
he's gonna be all did you forget about
me and i'm gonna be like yes
there's so many other creatures that
came along after you
siren ed all these other dudes five
nights at freddy's happened all this
stuff
so you go back you've been forgotten
just go into your woods and
shut up i'm cleaning i'm gonna wash you
away
no one who's face is gone because i
power washed it out of his existence
[Music]
and kaboom that's the roof
all done except for the trim which i'm
going to do now
[Music]
bam bam lam
this is ah you ah
stupid ladder thinks it's better than me
the underside the underside of this
whole house is going to be the death of
me
it's going to be the doom of me there
the face your shoe was cleaned oh window
oh window oh
window oh window
oh window
[Applause]
window frame window window frame window
frame
window frame window frame
why why window frame y
there well we got one you should not be
this difficult window frames
do i need to hit you with the turbo i
will win the frames all of your friends
are done
all of your friends are done oh now oh
now we're go oh
now we go you want you're just a
follower
yeah wait till everyone else is done
there you go you
wimpy baby
i don't even care anymore volcano comes
along blows me away i don't even care
anymore
blast my ass into the moon
for all i care actually do that i would
love that can i go to the moon please
i would literally do anything due to
space you don't know how much i'm not
kidding
[Music]
and these eaves are gonna be oh
the eaves
[Music]
this door is disgusting
it's like all the neighborhoods
children's just ran up and stuck their
chewing gum onto the door
for some reason as if it was some rite
of passage
and this was some haunted tree house in
the middle of the woods
and all their friends dared them to do
it and then i have to clean it up
[Music]
roof trim is not done in what world
is the roof trim not done now the roof
trim is really not done
ah aha the jump technique i forgot about
it over here
there we go okay i think that should be
just about everything here
which means i can move on i can move on
to something a bit more straightforward
missing link fact they're sometimes
called bigfoot because of their one big
foot
kinda like a bears the other one's small
like a cats i've found track evidence of
myself
okay why can't i walk under ladders
i know it's bad luck but honestly i
don't care i want the
these footprints are big wait a minute
wait a minute here
oh it all makes sense now
oh this is bigfoot's treehouse
oh ho ho ho the plot
thickens just like the dirt and the
smudge thickens with every level i go
through
oh ho ho
now that is an efficient use of soapage
don't want any evidence of bigfoot here
yeah it was helpful oh no it wasn't look
at all this schmutz left over yeah i
might as well have done the white
it does just as just about as good a job
except actually probably a bit more
thorough
[Music]
that's nice that's nice
nice nice
[Music]
50 done i smell a big big bonus when
this job is done
[Music]
i'm almost done with this big up top
side
almost done i mean i got the railing
which is going to be a [ __ ]
to itself but i'm not going to be able
to get that done from the inside because
it needs the outside as well
but it'll feel good to get this done i
want to make sure i get this trimmed
though
because if i if i have to wait around
for the trim on the top
or when i get to the outside then i'm
gonna have a bad time
[Music]
tada easy easy peasy
now this railing not so easy peasy
not as easy nor peasy but let's just do
it one
should i ah you know what actually i'm
gonna wait i'm gonna wait on that i'm
gonna wait on that
because i don't feel like doing it
therefore i won't do it
these are the muddiest damn stairs i've
ever seen in my life
[Music]
at least they i think they made the
underside just a little bit easier to
clean than the other than that
than the top so i am grateful for that
because it seems like i'm able to hit it
with easier nozzles than the other ones
but man that top is just filthy
[Music]
my
i know that i could get the scaffolding
and do this but i
so rarely get an opportunity to use the
turbo nozzle that i say
why not why not snipe this from a
distance
[Music]
missing link fact they but deposit their
sky bubbles
oh yeah the ability to talk just
exploded out of my face and i miss the
rest of that literally like i get so
caught up in this that i stopped talking
and then i just
completely lose any connection to my
ability to consciously talk and do a
let's play and you know all the things
that i would normally do
that i've been doing for 10 years this
game kind of just expunges it out of my
existence and i have no idea what i'm
doing
but i'm getting close to getting the
spiral staircase done which is awfully
nice
and i do like that but man this one is
um
this one's getting to me like ordinarily
like i'm just like super smooth
uh able to talk and do everything this
this reminds me of the playground
that's what this is see like the
skatepark stuff like that i love that
i love those things because they're
super big
surfaces and then i don't have to worry
too much about like getting all the
little itty-bitty details
i can kind of focus on the macro picture
and uh i'm able to
dial it in but this one just like all
the different
handrails the tiny slats the ability to
miss
stuff it's like oh i have to concentrate
i have to concentrate also i'm gonna
miss something like i
seem to have missed something on the
handrail probably on the outer side
i'm gonna go ahead and get this thing
because i
am not getting everything i need
so i need to find what i'm missing uh
it's all over the place
it's because i did the turbo therefore
these kind of look
clean from a distance but they're not
clean so i got to re-clean them
which is fine
it's fine part of the job it wouldn't be
part of the job if i actually did
everything right the first time but i'm
not gonna talk about that
[Music]
how are the steps not done yet i don't
know
i don't know i'm losing it
i'm losing it everybody i'm losing my
mind i'm losing it
i'm losing it i've lost it i'm losing it
and i've lost it
well my nose is running yeah
[Music]
i'm better i'm not better this staircase
is not
done
[Music]
i'm fine
the wash got to me a little bit guys the
wash got to me
somehow the steps aren't done yet and i
get that
i get that i don't get that but i get
that
how can there possibly be anything left
to wash
the way it's suggesting is suggesting
that i
am missing a huge chunk of this
staircase but i believe
that it's wrong what have i missed
what have i missed what is missing
what is missing what's missing i've gone
through the whole thing
this is what i don't like going through
things over again
what did i miss
what if i'm oh you oh okay oh okay
all right okay all right
okay i had to go proney i had to go
proney bologna to get this one
but it's still not everything it's still
not everything i have to go through
everything again
again this is what i don't like
ah staircase is done
which means that the handrail should
follow right
behind it done super
fast and efficiently
ah oh my god
oh man that was so annoying
that was so annoying oh my god that was
annoying
okay however god my nose my nose my
mouth
i'm losing it i'm losing my mind it's
too warm in here
my headphone thing is too short
i'm fine i'm fine
[Music]
i'm fine i just need to get to the tippy
top i need to get to the tippy top
i have to get to the tippy tippy top
okay
get on there stay damn it
really
hi i think i'm gonna end this episode
here because
i'm gonna lose my mind if i have to
continue this and do all
the rest 39 and i know that all the rest
that i've left is the railing
and the one thing i hate more than all
of the rest
in this goddamn game is rails
and there's this and then the flooring
which is fine but
the rails i'm gonna lose it if i have to
do the rails
so i'm not gonna do the rails until i
get to another episode that's future
me's problem
not me now when i'm done with this it
will be very satisfying
but for now i'm gonna lose my mind if i
keep going right now so thank you
everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below
oh and as always i will see you
in the next episode bye-bye
[Music]
you